So what did we learn about
exploring exploration, Charles?
>> Well, we actually learned a lot, but
really I think you can summarize
it in just a couple things.
We learned about bandits,
which is really about stochasticity and
randomness.
And in particular,
we learned about how we can
estimate what we know using Hoeffding
bounds and maybe some union bounds.
>> So, yeah.
In particular we employed
Hoeffding bound,
u nion bound to convince ourselves that
we have a sufficiently accurate estimate
that we can get near optimal reward
in these kind of non-sequential but
stochastic decision problems.
>> Right, and that's really important
because a lot of the time you don't know
what to do because you're not certain,
or
how certain you really
are about what you know.
And what the Hoefding and union bounds
tell us is how certain we really are and
so we can know when
we're certain enough.
>> Good, all right so
we have a stochastic world,
we want to learn how it works so
that we can get near optimal reward.
So we can optimize.
>> Right, so that was the first thing.
And then the second thing is we learned,
well, we learned about Rmax, really,
and how Rmax works specifically
with deterministic MDPs.
>> Right, and so that was about
optimism in the face of uncertainty and
how it would cause us to explore or
discover new stuff about the world,
kind of by planning ahead and
trying to get to states where
new information could be gained.
>> Right, well what it really says,
it's really,
we believe the grass is always greener
until we get there and learn otherwise.
>> All right, great.
This let us deal with
sequential decision making,
this let us deal with
stochastic decision making.
>> And then we combine them.
>> Right, where we used the bandit
idea to estimate the noisy parameters,
the transition probabilities and
so forth, and
we used the Rmax idea to make sure
that we visited things enough so
that we could get those
accurate estimates.
>> Right, so
Rmax basically remained Rmax, and
the bandit stuff helped us with
the transition probabilities, so
that we knew when we
actually believed them.
So, they were kind of,
this isn't really true, but
they were kind of deterministic enough.
So we knew enough to know what
the transition model is, and
once you know what the transition model
is you can just kind of go from there,
because then you can just estimate
the rewards and do the right thing.
>> Now this notion of, the way that
learning happens in the bandit
here where we actually kind of
distinguish between known and
unknown, can actually be generalized
even beyond the kind of general
MDPs that we're talking about here.
And I don't think we're going to get
a chance to talk about this, but
the idea of KWIK learning is learning
transition probabilities using methods
that know what they know.
And if it can distinguish between
known and unknown, it can associate
optimism with the unknown and then we
can make guarantees on how uniquely and
efficiently near optimal
behavior can be learned.
So this is kind of a learning
framework that my students and
I have been studying to try to
generalize beyond learning in
tabular MDPs to be able to generalize
between transition probabilities and
different parts of the MDP.
>> Well that all makes sense to me.
So then the only question is,
how does this help us do
practical reinforcement learning?
>> All right, so
that pretty much ends this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, okay, so just briefly,
I find that Rmax is actually a really
effective algorithm to use in practice.
We don't set C,
we don't set that parameter of how often
we need to see things to be what
the theory says we should set it to.
We usually set it to something much,
much smaller than that.
And we tried it by hand, strike a trade
off between making it too small,
in which case it might actually not
learn near optimal behavior, and
making it too big, in which case the
learner actually has to sniff around and
visit many, many, many, many state
action pairs over and over again.
So, Rmax itself does seems to
be a pretty effective algorithm.
It makes very good use of the data.
It's just we can't quite use it in
the theoretically specified way.
>> Okay, well that's good enough for me.
Seems pretty practical.
Okay, so we're done.
So, are we done with the class?
What's next?
>> We have more stuff!
We have what's next, next.
>> Oh cool, well I look forward to that.